[موسيقى]
هلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم زين العابدين
توفيق في الوقت الذي تحدث فيه الان تقع
واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى نبدا من باريس
في فرنسا تجمع الوطني لمين المتطرف
يختاروا جوده
من العمره 27 عاما فقط
في لندن وختام يوم من مظاهرات طلب
المشاركون فيها بانتخابات عامه مبكر
واحتجوا على موجه الغلاء المتعاقبه
طهران التي اعلنت اليوم اجراء تجربه
الناجحه لاطلاق صاروخ قادرا على حمل اقمار
الصناعيه الى الفضاء بعد ثلاثه اشهر من
اطلاقها قمر صناعيا بمساعده روسيا
وفي مواضع الحصاد هذه الليله
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه تتبادل القصف
بالمدفعيه الثقيله جنوب شرقي اوكرانيا
وعلي المره الاولى طهران تقر بتزويد موسكو
بطائرات مسيره وتشدد الطائرات ارسلت قبل
الحرب في اوكرانيا
بالكذب وتحذرها من عواقب ما سمته التواطؤ
مع روسيا
ازمه في باكستان رئيس الوزراء يتهم عمران
خان بالكذب في اتهاماته بضلوع الحكومه
والامن والمخابرات في محاوله اغتياله
ويطالب بتحقيق تتولاه لجنه القضائيه الجيش
اعتبرتها ماتخان غير مقبوله على الاطلاق
حزب انصاف يدعو الجيش لمحاكمته ضابط
مع اختتام اكبر مناورات جويه امريكيه
كوريه جنوبيه كوريه الشماليه تطلق اربعه
الصواريخ بالستيه قصيره المدى تفوق سرعه
الصوت بخمس مرات والاتحاد الاوروبيه
تهديدا للامن الدولي واقليمي ويقول انها
لم تمنح كوريا الشماليه وضع دوله النوويه
على الاطلاق
[موسيقى]
بعد يوم من تسريحه ويتر قرابه نصف عدد
موظف الشركه بعيدا يحذر وتر تنشروا
الاكاذيب في انحاء العالم الشركه تقول ان
تخفيض العماله كان على مستوى نقل في
الفريق المسؤول عن منع انتشار المعلومات
الكاذبه
وبخاوف كبار المعلنين تتصاعد
وفي لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على
مدرستها الرقميه نقشنا المخاء فالمتصاعده
سواء الرسميه او بين الافراد بعد تسريحه
تويتر قربه النصفي عدد العاملين في الشركه
الرئيس الامريكي حذر من القادم بالقول كيف
نتوقع ان يتحلل الاطفال بالقدره على
ادراكه المخاطر استطلاع رايكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد رحنا السؤال الثالث ما حجم
تاثير تصريح موظفي تويتر على الحد من خطاب
الكراهيه والمعلومات الكاذبه نتائج جاءت
على نحو التاليه 34% توقعوا تاثيرا كبيرا
لهذا الاجراء قال قرابته 24% ان التاثير
سيكون محدودا بينما اعتبر 42% انه لا
تاثير على الاطلاق لهذه الخطوه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات من
الرقميه لقائنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد
يوميا وانا نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله
وتتابعون ايضا في حصاد هذه الليله
بعد انتخابه زعيما للتجمع الوطني اليمنيه
المتطرف في فرنسا
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم والبدايه من تطورات الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا يتبادلت القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه القصف المدفعيه
الثقيل جنوبيه شرقيه اوكرانيه تقول لك ايه
ان قواتها دمرت مواقع روسيه في منطقتي
لوهانس ودونيستك اما القوات الروسيه
فاعلنت انها اسقطت صاروخين من نوع هاي
مارس وصدت هجمات في خيرسون ودمباس
في جبهه خرسون حيث قال الجيش الاوكراني ان
دفاعاته الجاويه اسقطت مروحيتين روسييتين
ودمرت ثلاثه مستودعات ذخيره تطورات دفعت
سلطات المواليه لروسيا الى اجلاء نحو 700
من سكان مدينه كفكا على نهر النيل برو
باتجاه المناطق الروسيه
وبينما قال الجيش الاوكراني انه دمر ريتلا
عسكريا بكامله حاولت القوه الروسيه نقله
من خرسون عبر نهر النيبرو الى جانب مركب
شحن روسي قرب
ذكرت وسائل اعلام روسيه ان الدفاعات
الجويه الروسيه اسقطت صاروخي هايمارس من
بين اربعه اطلقتها القوه الاوكرانيه على
المدينه في مقاطعه معارك واحتدمت بين
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاخرانيه في تسع
مناطق على الاقل وقالت مصادر عسكريه
اوكرانيه ان اشدها تلك التي دارت على محور
مدينه باخمود في المقابل افادت وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه بحدوث انفجارات ضخمه في
مستودعات للاسلحه والذخائر بتاعه الجيش
الاوكراني في مدينه بيكرفسك غربي دونيت
كما تم الرئيس الاوكرانيه
بالكذب بشان دعمها لروسيا بطائرات المسيره
وقال انها كذبت حتى عندما اعترفت بانها
قدمت تلك الطائرات لروسيا قال زلنسكي ان
القوات بلاده تسقط يوميا ماذا يقل عن 10
طائرات ايرانيه بينما تقول طهران ان قدمت
عددا محدودا منها قبل الحرب واكد ان بلاده
على يقين بوجود عسكريين ايرانيين يدربون
الروس على استخدام هذه الطائره
اليوم جاءت اخبار من ايران حيث قرر
المسؤولون هناك الاعتراف بتزودهم روسيا
بطائرات مسيره لكنهم كذبوا حتى في هذا
الاعتراف نحن نسكت على الاقل 10 مسيرات
ايرانيه يوميا في حين يقول النظام
الايراني انه زود روسيا بعدد محدود من
المسيرات قبل بدايه الغزو لكننا نحن
متاكدونا من ان خبراء ايرانيين دربو
ارهابيين روس على استخدامه هذه المسيارات
يجب على العالم بدل جهد اكبر للبحث في
التعاون الارهابي بين النظامي روسيا
وايران
كما حضر المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
دعمها لي موسكو واضافه في بيان على في
بيان اضافه على طيران ان تدرك ان عواقب
التواطي في جرائم العدوان الروسيه ضد
اوكرانيا سوف تفوق بكثير فوائد دعم روسيا
حسب تعبير البيان وقال المتحدث الاوكراني
وان وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه اعترفها علنا
بان بلاده كانت تزود روسيا بمسيره قتاليه
قبل اشهر من غزوها لاوكرانيا واضاف ان
الخارجيه وبالتنسيق مع الجهات الاوكرانيه
المعنيه ستواصل اتخاذه اقصى الاجراءات
الصارمه لمنع روسيا من استخدام الاسلحه
الايرانيه لما سماه قتل الاوكرانيين
وتدمير المنشات الاوكرانيه الحيويه
وكان وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير
عبد الله هيام قد قال ان بلاده وسلمت
روسيا عددا محدودا من الطائرات المسيره
قبل اشهر من بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا
واضاف الوزير و ان طيران اذا تاكدت من ان
روسيا استخدمت المسيارات الايرانيه في حرب
اوكرانيا فسيكون لديها رده فعل تجاه هذه
المساله
مبنيه على المصالح المشتركه واكد ان دول
غربيه تدعي بان ايران سلمت روسيا صواريخها
وطائرات مسيره لمساعدتها في الحرب الجزئيه
المتعلقه بالصواريخ لا اساس لها والجزئيه
المتعلقه بالمسيرات صحيحه فقد سلمنا عددا
محدودا الى روسيا قبل اشهر من حرب
اوكرانيا واتفقنا مع وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني ان يسلمون اي مستندات تثبت بان
موسكو استخدمت هذه السيارات في حرب
اوكرانيا واذا تم تسليمنا هذه المستندات
وتاكدنا بان روسيا استخدمت مسيراتنا سيكون
لدينا رده فعل تجاهها هذه المساله
وقال المتحدث باسمي هيئه الاركان التابعه
للقوات المسلحه الايرانيه العميد ابو
الفضل شكرجي ان بلاده ليس لها دور في حرب
اوكرانيا اوضح ان تسليم الاسلحه لروسيا
كان قبل اندلاعها ووصف شكرجي لاتهامات
لمواجهه الايران من جانب واشنطن وكيف
بالكاذبه مؤكدا لا اساس لها واوضح ان
الدول الغربيه بدات الحرب في اوكرانيا
وتزودها بكافه انواع الاجهزه العسكريه
ينظر الي من طهران هادئه الدبلوماسيه
والايراني السابق وبنكيف والاكزاندر
ميريكو رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في
البرلمان الاوكراني ابدا بضيفي من اكيف
لماذا كل هذا الانزعاج من المسيرات
الايرانيه
لانه في كل يوم الجيش الاوكراني يسقط على
الاقل 10 طائرات مسيره ايرانيه الصنع وهذا
يثبت ان ايران زودت روسيا باسلحه بطائرات
مسيره تستخدم ضد البنا التحتيه والاهداف
المدنيه
وفقا للقانون الدولي هذا يعني ان ايران
متواطئه بهذه الجرائم الروسيه ضد
الانسانيه وايران متواطئه في الاعتداء على
اوكرانيا مع روسيا في الحقيقه ان ايران
تشن حربا الى جانب روسيا ضد اوكرانيا
متعدده ايران نفذ انها كانت زودت روسيا
بالمسيرات ولكن مؤخرا اقرت بهذه الحقيقه
ولكن لسو حظ تستمر ايران بالكذب لانه وفقا
لمصادرنا وفقا لمعلوماتنا الاستخباريه
رجال الاستخبارات الايرانيون يدربون
القوات الروسيه حول كيفيه تشغيل هذه
المسيارات والربما حتى يقومونهم بتشغيلها
وبالتالي هذا يعني ان ايران مشاركه في
الاعتداء الروسي
من طهران يعني هنالك ايضا همم يعني
استغراب لصمت الايرانيين اولا نفهم ثم
صمطهم ثم اعترفهم مؤخرا بانهم بالفعل
زودوا روسيا بالطائرات مسيره كيف نفهم
الموقف الايراني
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لك التحيه
والمشاهدين في الحقيقه
منذ ان ادعت اوكرانيا انه ايران تزوج روسي
بطائرات مسيره ابان الحرب نفت ايران وما
زال التنفي وحتى في التصريح الاخير للسيد
نبيل عبد الله هيام اكد انه هذه الطائرات
المسيره اولا بعدد محدود وثانيا هذه
باعتها ايران عده اشهر قبل اندلاء الازمه
الاوكرانيه هذا الموضوع الاول استاذ عامر
الموضوع الثاني والاهم يعني بدي احضر
الاكاذيب التي مازال يكررها كل يوم
طيب يا اخي نحن اقترحنا خلال مكالمه
هاتفيه واتفاق بيننا وزير خارج ايران
ووزير خارج الاوكراني انه نخصص وفي دين في
دوله محايده اوروبيه وارسلت ايران هذا
الوفد كي يذهب الوفد الاوكراني ويتفاوضان
وتقدم اوكرانيا كل هذه الادعاءات الكاذبه
ويمنع الامريكي والالماني الاوكراني من
يفسد وفدا الى لكي ينتقم لغرفه الايراني
لحد الان نحن نطالب اما وفد مستقل من
الجهه محايده من الامم المتحده او
الاوكرانيين فليبعثوا يرسلوا بوفدهم ويثبت
ما الذي يمكن انه ما الذي يمكن ان تصل
اليه هذه اللجنه اذا كانت هذه الطائرات
تقول ايران انها ارسلت قبل الحرب ويقول
الاوكرانيون انهم يسقطون به منها 10
طائرات يوميا واذا كان الذي ارسل عدد قليل
يفترض ان يكون انتهى الان يعني هنالك ثقوب
في همم الروايه التي تقول عدد محدود اذا
قرنها بما يقوله الاوكرانيون فما الذي
يمكن ان تثبته اللجنه كيف يمكن التحقق
الحجه على الاوكراني انه نحن نقول قدم ولو
يعني قطعات طائره واحد اوكرانيه لحد الان
لم يقدموا طائره واحد اسقطتها اسقطتها
الاوكرانيين تحمل يعني بصمات ايرانيه
لماذا هم عاجزون او لماذا يتهربون من
ارسال اذا تقصي حقائق محايده او التقاء
الوفدين
فالاعلام والحرب النفسيه الشيء والدعاء
على الارض واثباتات هذه بالوثائق شيء اخر
طيب ضيفنا من همم
لماذا فعلا حتى كان هنالك وافترض يحدث
اجتماعا سحب منه الاوكرانيون واذا كان
وزير الخارجيه وثمن هذه المبادره للتحقق
فلماذا لا يثبت الاوكرانيون ادعاءاتهم
بانهم يسقطون 10 طائرات يوميا
لجنه برلمانيه
يوم امس كان لدينا نقاش مع ممثل الجيش
الاوكراني وهو بنفسه يتحقق من الطائرات
المسير التي اسقطها الجيش الاكراني وقد
شرح التفاصيل وكل الهيكليه والبنيه
التكنولوجيا
المسيره هذه التي ايرانيه
واعطيه لروسيا لدينا الادله وكما قلنا
نسقط في كل يوم اكثر من 10 طائرات مسيره
ايرانيه لدينا البراهيم
عليكم ان تقدم لكن اذا كنتم تسقطون
الطائرات الايرانيه بهذه السهوله لماذا
تعتبرون ذلك تستعيدارا لماذا تتحدثون بقلق
على المسايرات الايرانيه
وان فورشنر
نحن لا نتمكن من اسقاط كل الطائرات
المسيره التي
تستخدمها القوات الروسيه البعض من هذه
المسيارات
ضربت محطات طاقه كهربائيه ولذلك في كيف
وفي مناطق اخرى لدينا انقطاع في التيار
الكهربائي لان روسيا تستخدم المسيارات
الايرانيه لقصف البنا التحتيه المدنيه
عمدا وهذه جريمه خطيره وود ان اكرر ان
ايران متواطئه في هذه الجريمه مع روسيا
استاذ افقي يعني الايرانيون سكتوا كثيرا
قبل ان يعترفوا بوجود طائرات مسيره
ماذا لو ثبت بالفعل انهم ما زالوا يرسلون
طائرات مسيره لروسيا وان لهم خبراء كما
يقول الاوكرانيون
يعني هذه فرضيه نحن كما حضرتك اسالت من
ضيفك يجب اثباتها وقال السيد عمر عبدالله
الان في نفس هذه التصريح انه لو ثبت ذلك
نحن سنعيد النظر وتكون لنا رده فعل عندما
تتحدث ايران
انه تعال
ربما تمنع يعني من الان فصاعدا اذا ثبت
ذلك مثلا قطع غيار او تمنع التعامل على
هذا المستوى فالان نحن الذي يحسم الموقف
سيدي هو اثبات هذا الموضوع الان هو ناقض
نفسه بنفسه انه لم يقدم هذه الدلائل لجهه
محايده يقول قائد الجيش الاوكراني اثبت
لانا نحن الاوكرانيين يعني هذه الروايه
الداخليه هم يتداولها بينهم في حلقه مفرغه
نحن نؤكد انه فليكن هناك وفدا اوكرانيا او
هيئه محايده تثبت لنا هذه الدعايه الكاذبه
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا هذه ابقى هي دبلوماسيه
السابق من
طهرانكو رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في
البرلمان الالكترونيه
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نسالك خبيرا
عسكريا عن اسباب قلق اوكرانيا المتساعد من
المسيرات الايرانيه مقارنه مع سلاح
الصواريخ
[موسيقى]
نفى رئيس الحكومه الباكستانيه شهباز شريف
اي صله له او لوزير الداخليه في حكومته او
مسؤولين في المخابرات بمحاوله اغتيال
الفاشله لسلفه عمران خان وتعهد شريف
بالاستقاله من منصبه اذا ثبت تورت ضلوعه
في الحادثه وقال ان التحقيقات كفيله
باظهار حقيقه الدعاء خان وفق تعبيره ومن
ناحيه الثانيه عبر الناطق باسم القوات
المسلحه الباكستانيه على الرفض الجيش
لاتهام حزب انصاف بازامه عمران خان لضابه
برتبه جنرال في الاستخبارات بالتخطيط
الاغتيال الرئيس الحكومه المقال كما دعاء
الحكومه للتحقيق حذر من ما غبت التعرض
لضباط الجيش
من دبر الامر وهي تبحث عن الحقيقه تسال
باكستان ايضا عن الدوافع ذلك كله ما يفترض
ان تحدده التحقيقات في محاوله اغتيال رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان هو خالفه في
المنصب يرد على اتهاماته
يتعهدوا شهباز شريف بالاستقاله اذا ثبت
الاتهامات التي اطلقها سلفه بحقه
او الضابط الكبير في المخابرات في محاوله
فانني لن ابقى لحظه واحده في منصب ولن
امارس اي دور سياسي بقيه حياتي لمصلحه
باكستان الوطنيه ولمصلحه الديمقراطيه في
البلاد لابد من التوتر لنهايه لاتهامات
خان فاما اننا مخطئون او انه هو المخطئ
وهو ما ستكشفه التحقيقات
كان ذلك ردا على شقوق خان التي اطلقها
كاليقين فقد وضع وحزبه انصاف كل من رئيس
الحكومه شهباز شريف ووزير الداخليه
وجينيرال في المخابرات العسكريه في دائره
الاتهام ثم حدد طريقين الى ثالث لهما اما
ان تحدث ثوره سلميه في باكستان او ثوره
دمويه
سلسله من الاغتيالات ومحاولات الاغتيال
استهدفت قاده سياسيين وناشطين وقضاه لا
تريد ان يراقه مزيد من الدماء
وما تخشاه الان اكثر هو ان تمضي بها
محاوله اغتيال رئيس الوزراء المقال نحو
المجهول
والخطوره بدات المؤسسه العسكريه النافذه
في باكستان في مزاعم بتورط احد ضباطها في
التخطيط لمحاوله اغتيال عمران خان اي يكن
من دبر الامر فان التنفيذ تم في واحده من
الفعاليات المطالبه بانتخابات مبكره في
البلاد المنقسمه سياسيا والمحاصره بما تعب
اقتصاديه
لم يقف عمران خان عن مطالبه حكومه شهباز
الائتلافيه بذلك منذ الاطاحه به في حبر
الى الماضي في اقتراع برلماني لحجم الثقه
والان لا يظهر الرجل اي علامات على
التراجع بل يتعهد بالعوده الى احتجاجات
الشارع ثوره عفيه نجم الكريكت السابق ماض
في لعبه سياسيه لها قواعد خاصه يدرك انها
قد تكلفه حياته
مين السبب ينضم الى اعجاز احمد الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ
اعجاز يعني هذه المحاوله ليست الاغتيال
الاول في باكستان او المحاوله الاولى
هنالك اغتيالات نجحت بالفعل اطاحت بثلاثه
رؤساء حكومه وهنالك من يقول ضياء الحق
ايضا تم اغتياله لكن ما المختلف في هذه
المحاوله من جانب على حياه عمران خان
والجوز السياسي
خالد ابن عمي
شعبيه كبيره في باكستان وبالنسبه الى عدد
كبير من
الباكستانيين هو يحظى
بكبر قدر من الشعبيه بالمقارنه مع القاده
السياسيين الاخرين حيث انا شعارات التي
اعتمدها عمران
السياسيه علاقه دعما في اوصاد المجتمعات
المختلفه في باكستان
وكانت تركز بشكل كبير على شباب الباكستاني
على الباكستاني وبالتالي معظم داعمي عمران
خان هم من الشباب وايضا النساء والفتيات
هنا
عمران بشكل
وليس اول سياسي يحظى بشعبيه في باكستان
كان هنالك سياسيون لهم شعبيه ايضا بنازير
بوتوكانات لا شعبيه نواه شريف في مراحل من
حياتي كانت له شعبيه لكن الان نحن نتحدث
عن تصريحات يعني يمكن عدم همم فمها مثل
تصريح رئيس الحكومه بان همم
بيتحدى عمران خان ان يثبت انه طالع ويتحدث
عن تصريحات عمران خان بانها اكاذيب وكان
محاوله الاغتيال لعمران خان كانت ملفقه
وليست حقيقيه
جنوب مع هبه
السياسيه مختلفه وبيئه سياسيه مختلفه في
باكستان الفرق الاساسيه بين القاده الذين
كان لديهم شعبيه في الماضي واعمران خان هو
ان عمران خان هو اول من تحدث عن
المؤسسات السياسيه
الباكستانيه التقليديه بطريقه منفتحه
ومباشره امام الشعب الباكستاني
وهذا وجه عليه
انا اسال عن تصريحات رئيس الحكومه لو تسمح
لي عذر للمقاطعه الاسئله عن تصريحات رئيس
الحكومه الذي يتهم
يتحدث فيها يرد فيها على اتهامات عمران
خان بمسؤوليه الحكومه ووزير الداخليه رئيس
الحكومه ووزير الداخليه وقائد بالضابط
بالمخابرات ويقول انها اكاذيب وانها توفيق
همم هل
ان المحاوله الاغتيال كانت ملفقه ايضا
في الحقيقه كنت اود ان اصل الى هذه النقطه
بنسبه الى الوضع الراهن في باكستان نحن لا
يمكننا ان نستثنى هذا هذه الاتهامات من
البيئه السياسيه الباكستانيه هذا امر
معتاد ولكن تسميه
قاده كبار في همم وزاره الداخليه والجيش
الباكستاني هو ال- همم همم
هذا الشخص
لديه عدد كبير من الجواسيس وهو يعمل في
مجال الاستخبارات
وكان فاعلا في باكستان عمران خان اتهمه
الشخصيه هذا الجنرال العسكري وهذا غير
التقليدي ما من احد في السابق قام بذلك
وهذه مساله اشكاليه في المجتمع الباكستاني
وفقا للقانون الباكستاني يجب ان
يقوم الشخص الذي يلقي الالتهابات يجب ان
يثبت ان لديه براهين كافيه لتدعيم الحجاج
التي لديها وبالتالي رئيس مجلس الوزراء
ردت وقال ان وسوف يشكل لجنه للتحقيق بما
قاله عمران خان
طيب معنديش
طلب طلب
الصحفي هو المحل الاساسي من اصابه اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
انهت شركه تويتر خدماتي حوالي 50% من
موظفيها في كل انحاء العالم بحسب وثيقه
داخليه ويتوقع ان يصل عدد الموظفين الذين
سيتم الاستغناء عنهم الى نحو ثلاثه الاف
و75
قال ان القراره كان الخيار الوحيد المتاح
لان المؤسسه تخسر اربعه ملايين دولار
يوميا واشار لان تويتر تشهد انخفاضا هائلا
في الارادات بسبب ضغوط على المعلنين حسب
تعبيره وكانت صحيفه الاستروجين ذكرتها
الشركات الكبرى من بين الخطوط الجويه
المتحده جنرال مايلز وفايزر واودي علقت
اعلاناتها دخلت اليوميه عن هذه الشركه
قولها انها ستراقب توجهاتها لماسك قبل
العوده للاعلان على منصه تويتر وفي تعليق
له على صفقه الاستحواذ على تويتر نقلت
رويترز عن الرئيس الامريكي القوله ان ماسك
اشترى خاصه تنثر وتنفث الاكاذيب في ارجاء
العالم
هذا هو نقلت قناه ام بي سي نيوز الامريكيه
عن مصادر مطلعه قولها عند تسريح الموظفين
الجامعيه في تويتر استهدف في المقام الاول
الفرق المسؤوله عن تتبع المعلومات الماضله
مما قد يعرقل قدرات الشركه على حظر
المحتوى المحظور ويتسبب في فوضى خلال
انتخابات التجديد النصفي ومن جهه نقل موقع
عن شخص مقرب من شركه تويتر انه تم تصريحه
نصف الفريق السياسه العامه في تويتر بمن
في ذلك اعضاء الفريق المسؤول عن التحقق من
حسابات السياسيين واضاف الموقع وانه منذ
شراء تويتر اثر ماسك على ان على ان تظل
سياسات الشركه بشان اداره المحتوى
والمعلومات المضلله ساريه
وبينما تاتي اغلب ايرادات منصه التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر من الاعلانات اوقفت شركات
وعلامات تجاريه الانفاق على الاعلان على
المنصه بمجرد استحواذ علم ماسك عليها وفي
ظل جدل يتعلقوا بمواقف ماسك وقرارات
الاخيره التي بموجبها قام بطرد المديرين
التنفيذيين والتقليص عدد الموظفين اذا
يثار جدله الاخر بشان المحتوى والتضليل
والقيم التي بنيت عليها تويتر خصوصا ما
يتعلق منها بحريه التعبير
كان عام 2006 موعد لولاده موقع تويتر على
يدي كل من جاك
دورسيستون
عدد مستخدميه بشكل مستمر واصبح متاحه
للجمهور في نوفمبر عام 2013 بعد طرح اسومه
في البورصه الامريكيه ونهايه اكتوبر
الماضي اتمنى
على شركه تويتر مقابل 44 مليار دولار
لينهي حاله جدلا وخلافات اندلعت بين
الطرفين كتب ماسك في تغريده الله الطائر
اصبح طريقا في اشاره منصه تويتر لكن جدلا
كبيرا تار بشان مستقبل منصه ودورها وحريه
التعبير التي تدافع عنها غرض المالك
الجديد لتويتر قائلا ان النشطاء الذين
يطيرون مخاوف طريقه الاشراف على المحتوى
على تويتر يحاولون تدمير حوريه التعبير في
الولايات المتحده
ومساله المحتوى من نقاط الجدال وبينها نشر
الاخبار والمعلومات المضلله والتحريض
والحث على الكراهيه وكان من ابرز حضر حساب
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب على المنصه
بعد احداث اقتحام الكونجرس في 2020
وللمصادفه يعود الجدل باستحود ماسك على
تويتر وسط مخاوفا من تزايد المخاطر
الامنيه خصوصا مع اقترب الانتخابات
النصفيه
بلومبرج اشارت الى منع وصول بعض الموظفين
في تويتر الى الادوات الداخليه في الاشراف
على المحتوى مما حدى من قدره منصه على
التصدي للمعلومات بشان الانتخابات وعلى
طريقه الرئيس دونالد ترامب المثيره طرد
ماسك جميع المديرين التنفيذيين من ترك
اجروال الى ثراء وهي كبيره مسؤولي العملاء
في تويتر رغم ان عدد مشترك الموقع يبلغ
النحو 240 مليونان وهو اقل من ما هو الحال
في منصات مثل فيسبوك وتيك توك الا تويتر
شكرت فضاءا رئيسا عاما للناس للنقاش وسيله
اتصال فعال لغلبيه السياسيين وصناع القرار
والمشاهير والمؤثرين والصناع الراي
والمفكرين وسعدت المتظاهرين في التشبيك
والضغط والحشد والتنظيم والتعبير عن
انفسهم في حديثه في مؤتمر تايد هذا العام
في فانكوفر قال ماسك مبررا شرائه تويتر
احساسي وحدثي القويان يخبراني ان امتلاك
منصه عامه موثوق بها الى اقصى حد وشامله
على نطاق واسع امر بالغ الاهميه لمستقبل
الحضاره تلك مقاربه ماسك وهو في نهايه
مستثمر وتحويل منصه مثل تويتر الى شركه
خاصه ينطوي على مخاطر عديده قد تمس ايضا
الخصوصيه والبيانات الشخصيه للمستخدمين
وقد يكونوا مصدر الخوف الاكبر ان يؤدي
استحواذ شخص واحد على منصه تويتر الى رهن
ابرز القيم الديمقراطيه التي تمثلها
المنصه وهي حريه التعبير
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه مناوره
جويه مشتركه هي الاكبر على الاطلاق بينهما
اعتبرتها استفزازيه
الشماليه اليوم
قصيره المدى باتجاه البحر على ما اعلن جيش
كوريا الجنوبيه في احدث عمليات اطلاق
الصواريخ التي اجرتها بيونديال هذا
الاسبوع الاتحاد الاوروبيه كوريا الشماليه
وقال انه لا يمكنها لا يمكنها ولن تمنحها
اطلاقا وضع دوله النوويه
تتصاعد حاله التوتر في شبه جزيره الكوريه
وترسم التطورات الميدانيه في الكليتين
وتبادل الاتهامات الصوره القاتمه للموقف
هناك المتازم اصلا بعد ايام من التطورات
الميدانيه وتبادل الاتهامات بشالها تحدث
بيان رئاسه الاركان المشتركه الكوريه
الجنوبيه يوم السبت عن رصد اربعه صواريخ
بالستيه قصيره المدى اطلقتها كوريا
الشماليه من تونس
الشماليه باتجاه بحر الغرب وذكر ان
الصواريخ قطعت نحو مئه وثلاثين كيلو مترا
وبسرعه
وهو المؤشر الذي يبين نسبه السرعه
الحقيقيه الى سرعه الصوت ما يعني ان
الصواريخ المطلقه تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت
بخمس مرات
واختتمت السبت ايضا تدريبات العاصفه يا
رضا بين كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
والتي وصفها المراقبون بانها اكبر استعراض
للقوه اشتركت فيه مجموعه من اكثر طائرات
البلدين الحليفيين تطورا ونشر سلاح الجو
الامريكي في خاتمتها قاذفتين من طراز بي
وان بي بعيده المدى وهي عماد القادري
الامريكيه وذكر انها قادره على ضرب اي
مكان في العالم وكانها ترد بذلك على
التحرك الاخير ل 180 طائره حربيه كوريا
الشماليه
هذه القاذفه تثير قلقا خاصا لدى بنيان
باعتبارها من الوصول الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه ونشرها في التدريبات مع كوريا
الجنوبيه يعتبر تهديدا كبيرا لها وهددت
سيول واشنطن بدفع ما وصفته باكبر الثمن في
التاريخ وبعد ساعات من ذلك اعلنت سول
رصدها اطلاق جارتها الشماليه اكثر من 80
قذيفه مدفعيه في البحر فيما اعتبرته
انتهاكا لاتفاق عام 2018 والذي انشا
مناطقها عازله للحد من التوتري بين
الجانبين تصاعد التوتر الابراهيم في شبه
جزيره الكوريه والذي ياتي في وقت لا تزال
فيه المفاوضات حول الملف النووي الكوري
الشمالي تواجه طريق مسدودا منذ توقفها
عاقبه قيمتها نوي عام 2019 والتي لم تحرز
اي تقدم
وتتوجه الولايات المتحده وحليفتها كوريا
الجنوبيه وغيرهما من ان بيونغيانغ تستفيد
من اطاله امد النزاع وترى وشنطا وشول حسب
استراتي يديهما طبعا النبي يونج تصعد من
حده التوتر توطئه الاستئنافها المتوقع
للتجارب النوويه للمره الاولى منذ عام
وانها تمت الترتيبات المتعلقه بذلك
جنوب غرب انجلترا
الباحث المختص الشؤون الكوريه بجامعه ليدز
ابدا معك بتصريح الاتحاد الاوروبيه ان كل
هذه الخطوات الكوريه الشماليه لن يضعها
ابدا في طائفه الدول النوويه لماذا
يضعها في طائفه دول النوويه
في الاقرار بالواقع على مستوى اوروبا ان
كوريا الشماليه اذا ما كنا نتحدث عن
الوقائع والحقائق
وليس منارغب به انها دوله النوويه واجره
تجارب النوويه منذ عام 2006 وهي ست تجارب
وهي تستعد للتجربه او الاختبار السابع اذا
هناك استخدامات يمكن ان تكون سيئه وان
كوريا الشماليه يفترض ان لا تقوم بهذه
التجارب والاختبارات وفقا لاتفاقيه او
معاهده عدم التيشار وهذا ما وافقت عليه كل
الدول بما في ذلك الصين وروسيا في الماضي
من اجل حمايه هذه المعاهده يفكر البعض انه
يمكننا ان نقر بالحقيقه وهو ان كوريا
الشماليه هي قوه النوويه ولكن بنسبه اليه
نحن في وضع خطر والايام القليله الماضيه
تشير الى ذلك ما مدى خطوره ما يجري الان
هل هو يعني مجرد همم حلقه جديده من حلقات
التمارين
والاستفزازات سواء من هذا الجانب او من
ذاك ام نحن بمواضع مختلفه هذه المره
هذا هو السؤال الاساسي ولكن المشكله هي
اننا نجهل الاجابه عن هذا السؤال طبعا انا
في بعض الاحيان عند
مشاركتي همم اتحدث دائما عن هذه
الاستفزازات بعد هذه الاستفزازات يكون
هناك مباحثات سلام اين المفاوضات في العام
2018 او 2019 ولكنها انتهت القلق الان هو
حجم هذه الاستفزازات في المقابل الولايات
المتحده اجره مع كوريا الجنوبيه اكبر
مناورات عسكريه تاريخيه وهذا ما ادى الى
رد الفعل الكوري الشمالي عمليه اطلاق هذه
القضاء ونحن نتحدث عن الدجاجه والبيضه من
جهه اخرى ولكن المشكله هي انهما من
مباحثات ما من مفاوضات كوريا الجنوبيه لا
تتحدث مع كوريا الشماليه في كوريا
الجنوبيه هناك قياده محافظه غير مهتمه
بالخراط في حوار مع كوريا الشماليه على
عكس
القياده السابقه جو بايدن قد يكون مهتما
غير انه لديه انشغالات كبيره داخليه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليس اقلها
الانتخابات التجديد النصف الكونغرس اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا من جنوبي غرب انجلترا همم
الباحث المختص في الشؤون الكوريه بجامعه
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا التي انتخب حزب التجمع الوطني
اليمني المتطرف فيها منتخب وجها جديدا
خلفا لمريم لوبان وفي خطابه الاول هجم
جعدم باديلا البالغ من العمر 27 عاما فقط
هجمات
اغلاق فرنسا بالمهاجرين غير النظاميين
مؤكد ان حزبه سيعمل على الحد من الهجره
باقصى ما يكون
منيو المكان
الفرنسيه بتصدير اللاجئين غير الشرعيين
الى قرانا يريد وزير داخليته تسريع
التسويه الاوضاع القانونيه لهؤلاء لقد
قلنا ذلك بالنسبه لهم الهجره مشروع اما
بالنسبه لنا فيجب تنظيمها وكبحها
من باريس
ومرصد التطرف اساسي بمركز
للابحاث
سيدك اهلا وسهلا بك ماذا يعني صعود هذا
الشاب الى
رئاسه هذا الحزب اليمني المتطرف
وصل
على العمل على مستوى الجمعيه الوطنيه في
فرنسا وبنسبه اليها المهمه هو ما يحصل في
البرلمان كي يتمكن الفرنسيون في العام
2027 من انتخاب رئيس او رئيس
في صدره رئاسه الفرنسيه
طبعا
ينحدر هو نفسه من اصول مهاجره يعني وصول
مهاجره ايطاليه خليط من اصول ايطاليه
واصول جزائريه
كيف نفسر موقفه من الهجره
برتغاليه
اسبانيا من الاندماج في المجتمع الفرنسيه
والثقافيه الاساسيه حيث ان هذه الهجره اتت
من بلدان المسيحيه كاثوليكيه وهؤلاء
الاشخاص يعتبرون ان الهجره الحاليه التي
تاتي من الشرق الاوسط من بلدان الافريقيه
هذه الهجره لا تتشارك نفس القيم نحن نتحدث
عن الاسلام والذي هو لا يبدا في المباد
الخاصه بالمجتمع الفرنسي اما بالنسبه الى
هؤلاء المهاجرين ليس بصفهم ان يندمجوا في
المجتمع
يعني وجود مارين لوبانكا زعيمه للكتله
البرلمانيه للحزب
وجود هذا الشاب جوردن على راس الحزب همم
كيف يعطينا فكره عن كيفيه اداره معسكر
اليمين المتطرف لمعاركه في المستقبل
السياسي منذ نهايه الانتخابات تصاعدت
الاصوات التي تتحدث عن اتحاد اليمين في
فرنسا
[موسيقى]
ومع الجمهوريين وبالتالي بنسبه الى برديلا
يجب يتنبها الى هذا الخيار لان
الطبقه العماليه التي تصويت لصالح مرين
الثاني لن تقبل بها هكذا تحالف من قبلها
شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس جونيف كامو رئيس
مرصد التطرف السياسيه بمركز جمب جورج
الابحاث
خرجت مظاهرتهم في العاصمه البريطانيه لندن
المطالبه بجهود اكبر لمساعده المواطنين في
مواجهه ارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه المظاهره
دعت اليها ما يعرف بمجلس الشعب وهي حمله
غير حزبيه تناهض الاجراءات التقشفيه في
بريطانيا
ونقابات وجماعات متعدده من عموم البلاد
افرادا وجماعات اخرجتهم موجات الغلاء
المتعاقبه التي ضربت بريطانيا في العامين
الاخيرين تعددت انتماءات المشاركين في
الحشود السائره في شوارع العاصمه وتعددت
ايضا مطالبهم لكنهم توحدوا في مطلبين هما
الابرز
والغاء القوانين التي تقيد حق الاضراب
حاليا
لمقاومه هذا الامر كجزء من الحركه العامه
لمقاومه ازمه ارتفاع فقط
يعرض المتظاهرون هنا ايضا تغيير ثلاث
رؤساء حكومات في البلاد خلال الاشهر
الاربعه الاخيره باقتراع داخلي في حزب
المحافظين الحاكم هذا في رايهم احد اسباب
ازمه البلاد الحاليه
[موسيقى]
مستمر من اجل زياده الدخول في مواجهه
موجهه غلاء لم تتكرر في هذه البلاد منذ
سنوات عديده
غلاء تعددت اسبابه وعلى راسها تداعيات
الحرب في اوكرانيا وتداعيات جائعه كورونا
اسعار اغلب السلع هنا قفزت اكثر من 25%
خلال العام الاخير الفاقه الزياده احيانا
60 في المئه خلال اثنا عشر شهرا هذا في
مقابل الزيادات طفيفه في دخول العمال
والموظفين تقيم عاده باحاد الارقام لا
بعشراتها اسد الله الصاوي الجزيره لندن
نعود الى اقراري ايران لاول مره بارسال
مسيرات الى روسيا مع التشديد على انها
ارسلتها قبل الحرب في اوكرانيا السؤال
الذي يفرض نفسه هو لماذا تشكر الطائرات
المسيره تحدي الاوكرانيا اكثر من الصواريخ
يمكن ان تستخدم الطائرات دون الطيار او
الطائرات المسيره في الاستطلاعي والمراقبه
او كما نستطيع من الجو لكن ابسط طريقه
الاستخدام هو ان تحلق باتجاه الهدف ثم
تنفجر فيه ويمكنوا لما يسمى بطائرات
كاميكازي المسيره او الانتحاريه كطراز
شاهد الايراني ان تتكلم مبلغا زهيدا فقط
يوازي ثمر سياره صغيره تطير كل طائره
مسيره ببطء بما يسمح باسقاطها ببندقيه
عاليه الدقه ولا تحمل الا حموله صغيره من
المتفجرات توازي قذيفه فعاليه لكنه
بامكانها ان تقطع مئات الكيلو مترات
وبسبب انخفاض تكلفتها يمكن ارسال طائرات
مسيره باسراب كبيره مما يجعل من الصعب ااا
منع واحده او اثنتين من اصابه الهدف او
الحاق الضرر المرجو الدفاعات الجويه
المتطوره التي تستخدم لحمايه الاهداف
عاليه القيمه والاهميه من الصواريخ ليست
مناسبه تماما لصد الطائرات المسيره رخيصه
الثمن تطير كسر كما قلنا يمكن لسرب من
الطائرات المسيره ان يكلف اقل من صاروخ
ارض جو واحد لاسقاط احداها فحسب هذا ما
يتعلق بالطائرات المسيره او الطائرات بدون
طيار ماذا عن سلاح الصواريخ الذي كسفت
روسيا استخدامه في حرب اوكرانيا في حربها
على اوكرانيا للسينما في الاسابيع الاخيره
يعتقد ان صواريخ كليبر على سبيل المثال
قادره على التحليق لمسافه 1000 كيلومتر
وتنزل على اهدافها بسرعه تفوق السرعه
الصوت بعده اضعاف
فريق كالبر تحمل رؤوسا حربيه تزن اكثر من
400 كيلوغرام بما يشمل امكانيه حمل رؤوس
نوويه
هي مصممه لتدمير اهداف العسكريه محميه
ومحسنه جيد جيدا وعاليه الاهميه والقيمه
كالسفن الحربيه ومراكز القياده يتطلب
واسقاطه ودفاعات جويه معقده ومتطوره
مناسبه للدفاع عن اهداف محدده ومهمه اكثر
من حمايه منطقه كبيره المساحه لكن من غير
المعروف عدد الصواريخ التي تمتلكها روسيا
ويعتقدوا ان المخزون الروسيه محدود مما
يجعل استمرار تنفيذ ضربات صاروخيه على
نطاق واسع امرا غير قابل للاستدامه الحديث
في هذا الموضوع معنا في الاستوديو اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اهلا وسهلا بك يعني كما شرح هنالك بين
الطائرات المسيره من حيث السعر من حيث
الوظائف من حيث
الوصول للاهداف وبين صواريخ همم
لماذا ينزعج الاوكرانيون كثيرا
هذه المسيرات الايرانيه تحديدا
فمن شهيد
بتكلفه يعني المختصر ثمان زهيد يدفع بها
20,000$ مقابل ان تدمر محطه كهربائيه او
محطه كهربائيه
33% من قدرات اوكرانيا في الطاقه
الكهربائيه تم تدويرها ليس جميعا بمجملها
من الطائرات المسيره ولكن الطائرات
المسيره في الفتره الاخيره بدات تاخذ بعدا
جديده قديما هي ظهرت في الحرب العالميه
الاولى
واستخدمت بصوره بعد 11 سبتمبر لكن استخدمت
من دول التنظيمات راديكاليه ارهابيه
لاغتيال شخصيه معينه كما تم اغتيال همم
هو غيره ولكن في السنوات الاخيره لا اصبح
لها دور رئيسي لا اقول الدور الحاسب لكن
الدوره رئيسه في الحرب همم الحرب الاداري
الارمينيه همم ما جرى في ليبيا سواء من
جانب حفتر او من جانب فائز السراج وما
يجري في اوكرانيا الان لماذا
لانه بدا هناك توجه حقيقي لدمج جهد
الطائرات المسيره بما يطلق عليه العمليات
المشتركه ما هي العمليات المشتركه هي
تكاتف وتازر واشتراك القوات البريه
والبحريه والجويه الان بدا يدخل بها بعد
اضافي تكلفه جيده امكانات جيده وبدات تتسع
مشكله الرئيسيه تدخل المعركه قبل بدئها
وتستمر طلتها تقدم الان من في بعد
الاستطلاع على سبيل المثال تستطيع ان تقدم
للقائد صوره ميدانيه حي عن ارض المعركه
لديه القدره على تعديل الاهداف وتعديل
اتجاه القوه تستخدم في حالات التشويش
الالكترونيه خاصه ضد منظومات الدفاع الجوي
على سبيل المثال وحده البانسر 12 مليون تم
تحديدها وتدميرها في سوريا
السيارات يعني اذا كان الاوكراني ويسقطون
يسقطون 10 طائرات او 10 طائرات يوميا ما
المشكله يعني هو هو سلاح يمكن تصدي له
تكمل المشكله في الاعداء وهذا يقولنا الى
نقطه جديده هي محط بحث وتفكير ان تستخدم
مستقبلا باعداد كبيره جدا لاخلاء لايجاد
ما يمكن ان يطلق عليه مجازا السد الناري
الجوي او حقول الالغام الجويه عندما تطرق
تطرق اسرابا بالعشرات والمئات وفي حرب بين
الدول الكبرى قد تكون بالالاف هذه تشكل
مانع عن جويا امام حركه الطائرات وبالتالي
مفهوم السيطره الجويه والتفوق الجوي يصبح
محدود الان في الازمه الاوكرانيه تحديدا
همم لا يوجد لا يوجد رقم واضح لعدد
الطائرات الايراني هناك من يقول 300 طائره
همم شاهد ولكن من يقول برقم موسى ال 2500
هناك الالاف استخدمت الصناعه روسيه
هذه اا يمكن ان تسقط منها اعداد كبيره على
سبيل المثال للحصر اعلى نسبه اسقاط طائرات
قد يفاجئ المشاهد هي كانت من قبل السعوديه
ضد الطائرات الحوثيين بلغت 95% من اعداده
الطائرات تم اسقاطها ولكن عندما هاجم
هذه المشكله
فرضا اطلق عندك 581 طائره اطلق من
الحوثيين اذا نجح منها 50 طائره او 20
طائره ماذا فعلت في شركه ارامكو شكرا
جزيلا لك الوها فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكريه
[موسيقى]
من جديد قضيه الطالب اللجوء بين حسابات
الحكومات والاعتبارات الانسانيه في
بريطانيا وصفت الايام الاخيره بالصعبه على
الحكومه التي تخضع لضغوط في طريقه ادارتها
لتدفق الطالب الهجوم في الاحداث تلاحقت
وابرزها الكشف عن مركز
باكثر من 4000 شخص في مكان تقدر سعته ب
1,600 وزيره الداخليه البريطانيه اثاره
الجدل عندما وصفت تدفق الطالب اللجوء
الذين يصلون الى المملكه المتحده على متن
قوارب صغيره بانه غزو اليوم اعتبرت الشرطه
البريطانيه هجوما استهدف مركز الاستقبال
الطالب
اعتبرته عملا ارهابيا وصلاح السبت ايضا
تسبب طالب اللجوء بالطلبات في مركز
الاستقبالهم بغرب لندن اثناء انقطاع
للتيار الكهربائي ويبدو ان الجدل سيستمر
طالما لم يتم وضع اليه واضحه وعادله
اتعامل مع ازمه طالب اللجوء شكرا لحسن
المتابعه وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]